Real good experience.
No idea what time?
No.
No concept of it.
Yeah,
it's fun to have.
Then it becomes like a
little man cave type.
The waffles were sacks
tightly wound.
What do get lower now
what it is is shit.
Depression.
I'm hiding your,
your putting the pressure
on yourself right now.
Think all my fucking money
back from Catholic school.
Yeah,
you actually did pay them.
I thought they just
take it out of your ass
in spades.
Rude.
You like religions so fun.
No it isn't.
No he's not.
We Jews have a decent,
she would use were way better
sense of you having the Catholics.
Catholics you saw about suffering daddy.
They returned.
They returned the radiators on in the
summer and in the winter they would turn
them off.
It's like why?
That's a real thing I have
trust might be my happy place.
I may be good
over the water or coffee.
I like the coconut oil and coffee thing.
That's good.
It's
good.
Doesn't regular code got water sharing?
They just went up or not one.
That one right there.
I think he called you
and shit talking Daddy.
Second
lender again.
That's okay.
Hmm.
Okay.
Get him NASA patches.
Ronda Rousey's real Ronda Rousey's
way harder than her patch.
The only female UFC fighter
than one gives a shit about,
cause she's hot.
Janet chronic ulcer right now.
She's an actor.
She used to fight.
She'd speak.
Maybe not.
Maybe not this grouping though.
Yeah.
I just want them all close to,
it's easier that way,
but he was saying,
I was planning on that one.
That's good to know that the exact
same shot in the matter where he was
nice.
I felt like I was like,
oh,
I'll have go to this podcast.
I think they thought I meant
like right now this second thing.
Yeah.
People get angry.
They're entitled Matt.
They want all their money.
Do you need to be up to date?
There's not enough free content from this
such
light.
Well that's the definitely like it's
going to be online later with the same
shot.
We were like,
wow,
I don't like the idea of broadcast
NBC in his country and like
the Ukraine.
I don't know that CEO
and you might have nine.
All I need it.
I get angry emails.
Yo marching songs,
shit by yourself.
I'll give you joy.
Fucking shoot.
You should be good to have greatness.
You see,
you used to be some special bro.
You fucking shows sell out.
How's that feel
lashing out.
They will totally do you want the
password are smoking tire county.
You can lash out.
All you want to
comment as a nominee for the,
obviously
that was nice.
I just took off start.
I would love to do that under account.
Yeah.
Just torching April.
Done.
You know why they got cocky?
No back up.
Think you get a better
recording.
Slip the fucking moment.
Dirty flux.
We'll be back soon.
Uh,
rogan.ting.com go there and save
25 bucks on a new android device.
The sexiest of the sexy,
including the HTC one m eight,
which I have my dirty little eyeballs on.
Dink,
dink,
dink.
Uh,
thanks to [inaudible] DOT com go to o.
N.
N I.
T you use the Codeword Rogan and save
10% off of any and all supplements for a
limited edition Kitty cat tee shirts and
all of the information about podcasts.
And,
uh,
any of Brian's comedy dates.
Go to death squad.tv
and get your freak on.
Including this Friday night we'll be at
the ice house in Pasadena in the little
room doing an episode of Thunderpussy,
which is a completely
improvisational podcast.
The audience yells out ideas.
He'd go onstage,
blitzed out of your fucking mind and
you talk mad shit and it's probably the
funnest thing I've ever done in my life.
Or you are on a Friday night.
I'm in Philly.
Go Fuck yourself Philly.
How bill burr was,
right.
All right.
Much love.
Big Kiss to everybody.
Ooh,
that was fun.
Anyone else got a back
college?
Yeah,
it was fine.
Right?
Was a blast.
I would have a pool table in a heartbeat.
I love having one brush with this one.
This is from the 1970s.
It's a gold crown too.
Scratching
fucker.
And I just,
hello?
Oh,
high ball goes in and you scratch.
You don't win
anywhere on the table.
Well,
you have is a nightmare.
It's not a victory.
You have a one ball that's wide open,
but the two balls tied up with the eight.
You'd have to play to
eight combination then
all have to go off of one more,
right?
Yeah.
I mean if you can possibly knock those
balls free once you make the one ball.
Do you see last standing?
The new one?
No,
no,
no.
You're good.
I heard it's better,
but because Rosanne's kidding.
Russell Peters is on
the behind the scenes,
but that you breakout
star from that Shimmy.
Shimmy Schumer is the answer.
Yeah.
We got along well.
You know what's his face as the host?
A JB Smoove.
Yeah.
Who's hilarious.
He's great move.
I love him.
That guy's funny as shit.
I readily wholefoods.
I ran into that dude out of nowhere.
It whole foods.
He's cool as fuck to ham on
that curb your enthusiasm.
Yeah.
He's a funny guy.
Counts on the fence for
doing Thunderpussy Friday,
so if you talk to about us.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'll get them in.
Yeah.
Bird crushes your shot.
Sexy bitch getting here.
Can we see,
get is dizzy on sitting.
That did have the funniest
fucking story last night.
It's in my pants.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
let's go.
Yeah.
You see if you can get them yo his number.
He's coming back to live here though.
June 1st or something.
So it up on the show.
No,
I think they're good.
They're just done for so many.
This chick seasons for a few startups.
He wants to me.
Thanks Joe.
Yeah.
Text me his number.
So when they started selling
tickets for Friday night,
was it sold out?
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean chuck,
they flip it.
Have the opposite.
This blackberry go,
whoa.
This is your shot.
And you can't even hit the one ball pit.
Yes.
Yeah.
Make an eight ball.
I fuck's bill.
Good luck.
Can
you want me drunk people
I've talked to her,
convinced her good pool.
It's quite fascinating.
You reviewed this job.
I'm telling you right pocket.
It seems like the
universe doesn't love you.
This is interesting.
Play pool as the good person that knows
how to play pool and somebody is able to
leave their shots.
Okay,
seriously.
Who?
Yeah,
I can do it too.
All ended up there.
No,
we should ask you a question.
Sure.
Did you go for the five ball
that way as opposed to this way?
Cause it,
but they do do that.
I shot,
I have two shots a on site
as possible or fly ball here.
The problem playing the size,
but we're gonna have
to hit it lighter have,
but I didn't come back properly
cause I have a bad angle.
I honestly,
if I did want to come back,
I would want to have an angle just about
two inches that way so that I could stay
on this side of the ball because that's
what scares me right there.
No,
it's not scary.
But this side pocket,
I couldn't,
I now I'm not going to play.
No,
I'm playing because of the angle plane
to come down here and then shoot this
ball in the side pocket because
the angle's not good though.
The Pool,
when you play a certain level,
it's all about um,
maintain the correct angle to
go from one ball to the other.
Ideally,
I would've liked to stop
anywhere around right here.
So funny.
I would,
I would have stopped.
I wouldn't try to stop here.
There's I one with that shot
as opposed to the natural.
That's good too,
but I wanted to,
once I make the ball,
I want to wind up right around
here and we're in town right now.
It's very hard to do that because we're
telling right now the natural angle of
shooting the ball and it's going
to make the ball go this way,
so now I have to adjust to that and I
have to make the ball go this way and then
out here and I have to hit it and I hit
up to here with low right hand English
so that when it hits the table,
it's the rail,
it bounces off and gets good.
The other thing that I
noticed is whenever I break,
I break with Tom English.
I've only broken that way.
I've never broken.
You broke,
you broke using the bottom.
It doesn't matter if
you could stop the ball.
I like to use bonding,
but some people do like to
talk as a plow suitable.
When you hear something
said they're good at pool,
you're like,
oh,
but how good are you?
I just hope I don't get left for them.
Easy shot and I can't make that right.
Well,
it's one of those things
where I find that,
like
when we're talking
about like archery play,
that's what Sean did.
Well,
people do archery and he got a tech.
You do a bunch.
That was good.
Very nice.
I got a couple more.
Oh No,
I'm good.
I can get out of your body
finally that take their
liver disease,
this whole other side of my body.
Why didn't you know where you live?
Yes.